It's about your 7am. We are flying on Thai airways from Bangkok to Manila
This is Micah's first flight.
Micah
You excited to travel for the first time?
Oh
Since we got an early morning flight. They're serving us breakfast on a flight.Croissant on the top there, some orange juice
This is what is this the yogurt?
And then we've also got some fruit and then my main
in the main Dish I got there the
should be an omelet and
Also, A
sausage in here
Oh, yeah, that is very simple-looking
triangle
a tail of an animal
Oh a shark fin. This is like a shark fin of a piece of omelette
It's actually kind of juicy
Let me get a bite of that that sausage here. Oh wow, that is erm
It takes a little bit of pressure to puncture that the bounciness of that sausage
And with some egg
Come on!
It's okay. Thank you
We should have about two more hours left on this flight until we land in Manila
travelling with a baby is much different than traveling without a baby, but apart from
semi emergency diaper change right at the beginning of the flight
Everything went really smoothly. I think Micah is a traveler
I've Visited manila. I've been to the philippines, maybe three or four times
But I've always had complications making videos like a last time my camera broke
So I am ready to be here. I'm ready to [eat] and hopefully no
Mishaps with the [camera], but anyway
I just wanted to give you a really quick update about my Youtube channel and the videos you can expect to see
About a year and a half ago
that was back... when was that Ying?  back in 2015
I think end of 2015
Ying and I took a trip to Bhutan
And it was an amazing trip.
It was an amazing opportunity to visit Bhutan and
I had
promised that I would be publishing a bunch of videos for you from Bhutan
But unfortunately due to the circumstances all the videos that I made had to be pre-approved
Before I could post them so I am happy to let you know that they have finally after a year and a half
they have finally been approved so I can publish the video and so I'm going to
starting
Starting right now in the next couple days. I'm going to start to Publish the whole Bhutan series
There's 20 videos in total and I will be posting a video on Sunday
on Wednesday
Friday and Saturday, so for videos per week. It's a bit different and more videos from my normal schedule
So it's a total of twenty videos. So that will be five weeks of Bhutan videos
So stay tuned. I think you'll really enjoy the series it is a
Bhutan is an amazing and enchanting destination, and I think it's very
Unseen and the food was awesome as [well] by the way. I've never eaten so much cheese in my entire life
But so that's what's going to happen for the next five weeks
You'll be seeing Bhutan videos and then after that
we're going to get straight to Filipino food, so
Stay tuned lots of videos coming your way
Thank you [very] much for all your support and for watching
This is just a quick little video. I wanted to show you mainly Micah's first trip outside of Thailand, and he did extremely well
And then I wanted to also share with you that I'll be publishing Bhutan video  followed by the philippines
and
That's as far as our travel plans go  for now. But hopefully lots of travels coming up
Thank you again for all of your support and for following and watching
And hope you're having a great day. See you on the next video